Lane Kiffin set to join us there Todd
he's all set
morning coach how are you hey Dan doing
great
how's life wonderful I don't know what
like I was just don't know what day it
is
happy holidays no a bummer but trying to
find some recruits how many
opportunities did you have okay
was the Arkansas offer was that real
well I can I'm not gonna get into
specific ones and you know respect to
those places but there were other
definite options you know but you know
this would ended up you know looking at
the roster a lot of great young players
and you know I was at Alabama for three
years and we lost two regular-season
games both were told myth so I got to
see you know what the place look like
you know when it was rolling so you know
it's not like going to place that you
got to you know do something never been
done before do you hear from Nick Saban
I have not I got a message through
someone that he was he was happy for me
and well-deserved but actually have it
on my list here because I slowed down
here to calm and thank him again how
much did you miss the SEC while you were
outside of it you know I didn't everyday
but you know I did you know when you
watch an SEC Championship or the
national championship the playoffs you
know or one of those big games in the
start of it you know you watched on TV
and think oh man you do you missed that
like it was like that was the only thing
that was missing Fe you was great
phenomenal support leadership
unbelievable players humble roster
coming back you know things hot as can
be so that part was difficult but you
know this was not about money
or ego this was strictly about you know
just just missing that that being at the
top level versus the top coaches and top
players in America but what would this
Lane Kiffin tell the lane kiffin who
coached the Raiders um slow down you
know think things through
decision-making not just major moves
like you know where you're going to go
work but daily moves and I think that's
part of natural maturity and I think
that's you know probably got too many
things too fast too early and wasn't
ready for him
how do you out recruit Alabama LSU
Georgia well we're not gonna win on all
the guys obviously no one does so you
know we just got to go sell our program
we're putting together a great staff one
that you know when you come here you
know it's it's gonna be easy to sell to
the kids hey you know you're gonna get
coached just like there you know with
great coaches and prepare you for the
NFL and and you know now we just got to
go go win game so that we can say the
same thing hey you're coming here to win
championships as well so there's a great
recipe here it's it's like I said it's
been done before now it just needs to be
done more on a consistent basis you know
there's been 10-win seasons but then
they'll be dipped down to five wins
we've got to build a program that stays
up there
well Ole Miss always wins the tailgate I
will say that they are good at that I've
heard yes yes I do remember I remember
field being rushed when they beat us at
Alabama down here and they beat us if
you play and they win the tarmacked
he'll gain as well and because when I
landed on the tarmac there was a couple
thousand person tailgate party going on
which I didn't know you could do it I'm
on the airport tarmac but a sec so
they're tailgating your arrival yes yes
EDA okay traveled and we'll look like I
mean I couldn't even see over them there
were so many people and I'd like the
plane land and you like look out and got
their phones arms light so it's like a
it was like a horror movie where like
they keep closing and I'm like wait take
it out of here but you've had a bad
tarmac experience before I had not
thought of that until joking they had
the press Carson brought that up I said
yes this is a much better tarmac memory
than the last one because you got fired
on the tarmac at USC by Pat Haden yes is
that how it like so the plane land
explain that to me
well I guess interior was on the tarmac
with a plane landed I got on the the bus
cuz it was like 4:00 a.m. and I was
going back to the office because it was
so late and I used to going home go back
to the office sleep for a couple hours
and get ready you know to get on next
week game plan and then the assistant
secretary came a cave stopped the bus
pulled me off
to bus you know as we were leaving the
airport and then brought me into the you
know the private Airport right there
into one of the little conference rooms
and and there I was hard so in theory it
wasn't on the tarmac wait so how did you
get home
someone drove me home I can't remember
one of the one of the workers there or
something like that right wait what I
still never understood that that they
like couldn't they wait like did you
have to be fired at 4:00 a.m. in the
morning when they take you off a bus I
guess they were so excited about you
know not excited but they were so no I
know it wasn't very worried about
getting rid of me like they just wanted
to get I guess get the whole thing over
with so you know they had the press
conference the next morning that oh sure
on you know to announce him as interim
head coach so I also saw a report or
picture rush because I think we had to
buy the next week so I don't really
understand why I was such a rush Bruce
Feldman told his story that and and orsa
Ron didn't get the full time job or
didn't get considered for long term
because his voice bothered some people
in the athletic department at USC did
you ever hear that yeah wait hey no hey
no by the way
LSU doing right now they're they're
doing I'm waiting for an athletic
director to say you know the reason why
we hired him he's got a really good
voice our fans can understand where what
is the next wrinkle with offense you're
an offensive minded guy what's next in
college football
well I got that question before I think
people are just still trying to figure
out how to catch up with where it's at
now defensively and old-school offenses
now you know around the country is he
getting fired you know because they
aren't keeping up so I don't really know
what the next step would be I mean it
seems like were so far we're so far out
there from where we used to be instance
at USC I mean we don't our offense looks
nothing like it did at USC you know and
so I'm proud of how we've evolving
actually even FAU or the last couple
years NFL teams have sent down coaches
you know to learn what we're doing to
bring it up to that level it's kind of
backwards in what you'd think NFL's copy
in college used to be the other way
around
yeah and I'm understand that and and I
think it's great that you're seeing some
of these head coaches in the NFL that
they're adopting the style of the
quarterback they're going to draft so
the transition becomes a little easier
we're certainly seeing that with Lamar
Jackson I think we saw that with Cam
Newton do you think that's gonna
continue in the NFL after smart you you
have to build
I mean they've always had built around
your quarterback but that used to just
mean get get good players you know now
it's your doing right you build around
your quarterback what plays are you
gonna call what system you're running
then you get people that fit that system
that never used to be talked about yeah
yeah I think that that's because I've
seen where Belichick has gone back to
college and you know talk to Mike Leach
and you know some of these are you know
Nick Saban and you know how long do you
think savings gonna coach for I think a
long time really yeah I do I mean what
else gonna do does he have any hobbies
he does golf but but he's miserable and
I mean I mean that in a way but he's
it's why he's so good he is singularly
focused on the university Alabama and
football at Alabama every minute of
every day even if he's golfing even
though he's on a boat I mean you know
he's got his recruiting calls to make
every night whether it's Christmas or
whatever it is it doesn't matter every
day's the same and that's why he's so
good so I don't know how he could retire
I think you know my dad's like that
you know turning 80 this year and still
coaching for us walking around the field
you know meeting with players you know
helping young coaches so you know there
are certain people like that I you know
come like prisoners like they can't go
in the real world like Shawshank
Redemption you know and when Brooks had
lured goes in the row where he can't he
can't do it wait I I need to be in
prison you know so they come back well I
remember Brent Musburger telling me that
Joe Paterno would die on the job because
he's a lifer that you know that you're
you're afraid to stop
and I think that you find this with like
Urban Meyer do you think Urban Meyer is
coming back to coach I do and that's not
from anything that urban has said to me
so
but maybe the NFL not college uh I don't
know he seems like maybe seems more of a
college fit just because his ability to
recruit but but maybe you know if he if
he wants to have a little more balance
in the college because college is you're
wrong you know the NFL NFL nowadays
coaches you know work half a year you
know because I've been FL PA and the
agreements they you know a lot of these
staffs are one week on one week off an
offseason which is you know they don't
happen in college well maybe we'll pay a
visit down to Oxford this this year I'll
bring me oh the Dan that's down there
and you know we'll uh little tailgate
down there pretty in the Grove baby know
that that I mean there there might be
NCAA violations there though coach I
don't know if I want Fritzi in the Grove
we're staying away from those down yes
we are
we're staying away from NCAA violations
hey coach congratulations and we'll be
in touch
appreciate it absolutely Lane Kiffin and
Happy Holidays to for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]